In our previous video, we
found the distance matrix,
which computes the pairwise
distances between all
the intensity values
in the flower vector.
Now we can cluster
the intensity values
using hierarchical clustering.
So we're going to type
"cluster intensity."
And then we're going to use
the hclust function, which
is the hierarchical clustering
function in R, which
takes as an input
the distance matrix.
And then we're going to
specify the clustering method
to be "word."
As a reminder,
the "words" method
is a minimum variants
method, which
tries to find compact
and spherical clusters.
We can think about it as
trying to minimize the variance
within each cluster and the
distance among clusters.
Now we can plot the
cluster dendrogram.
So-- plot(clusterIntensity).
And now we obtain the
cluster dendrogram.
Let's have here a little
aside or a quick reminder
about how to read a dendrogram
and make sense of it.
Let us first consider this
toy dendrogram example.
The lowest row of
nodes represent
the data or the
individual observations,
and the remaining nodes
represent the clusters.
The vertical lines
depict the distance
between two nodes or clusters.
The taller the line, the more
dissimilar the clusters are.
For instance, cluster D-E-F
is closer to cluster B-C-D-E-F
than cluster B-C is.
And this is well depicted by the
height of the lines connecting
each of clusters B-C and
D-E-F to their parent node.
Now cutting the dendrogram
at a given level
yields a certain
partitioning of the data.
For instance, if we cut the tree
between levels two and three,
we obtain four clusters,
A, B-C, D-E, and F.
If we cut the dendrogram
between levels three and four,
then we obtain three
clusters, A, B-C, and D-E-F.
And if we were to cut the
dendrogram between levels four
and five, then we obtain two
clusters, A and B-C-D-E-F.
What to choose, two,
three, or four clusters?
Well, the smaller the number
of clusters, the coarser
the clustering is.
But at the same time,
having many clusters
may be too much of a stretch.
We should always have
this trade-off in mind.
Now the distance
information between clusters
can guide our choice of
the number of clusters.
A good partition belongs to a
cut that has a good enough room
to move up and down.
For instance, the cut between
levels two and three can go up
until it reaches cluster D-E-F.
The cut between levels three
and four has more room to move
until it reaches the cluster
B-C-D-E-F. And the cut between
levels four and five has
the least room.
So it seems like
choosing three clusters
is reasonable in this case.
Going back to our
dendrogram, it seems
that having two clusters
or three clusters
is reasonable in our case.
We can actually
visualize the cuts
by plotting rectangles around
the clusters on this tree.
To do so, we can use the
rect.hclust function,
which takes as an input
clusterIntensiy, which
is our tree.
And then we can specify
the number of clusters
that we want.
So let's set k=3.
And we can color the
borders of the rectangles.
And let's color them,
for instance, in red.
Now going back to
our dendrogram,
now we can see
the three clusters
in these red rectangles.
Now let us split the data
into these three clusters.
We're going to
call our clusters,
for instance, flowerClusters.
And then we're going to
use the function cut tree.
And literally, this
function cuts the dendrogram
into however many
clusters we want.
The input would be
clusterIntensity.
And then we have to specify k=3,
because we would like to have
three clusters.
Now let us output
the flower clusters
variable to see how it looks.
So flowerClusters.
And we see that the
flower cluster is actually
a vector that assigns each
intensity value in the flower
vector to a cluster.
It actually has the same
length, which is 2,005,
and has values 1,
2, and 3, which
correspond to each cluster.
To find the mean intensity
value of each of our clusters,
we can use the tapply
function and ask R to group
the values in the flower
vector according to the flower
clusters, and then
apply the mean statistic
to each of the groups.
What we obtain is that the first
cluster has a mean intensity
value of 0.08, which
is closest to zero,
and this means
that it corresponds
to the darkest
shape in our image.
And then the third cluster
here, which is closest to 1,
corresponds to
the fairest shade.
And now the fun part.
Let us see how the
image was segmented.
To output an image, we
can use the image function
in R, which takes a
matrix as an input.
But the variable flowerClusters,
as we just saw, is a vector.
So we need to convert
it into a matrix.
We can do this by setting the
dimension of this variable
by using the dimension function.
So, let's use the
dimension function, or dim,
which takes as input
flowerClusters.
And then we're going to
use the combined function,
or the c function.
And its first argument
will be the number of rows
that we want for the matrix,
and that would be 50.
And the second argument would
be the number of columns.
Why did we use 50?
Simply because we have a 50
by 50 resolution picture.
Now pressing Enter,
and flowerClusters
looks like a matrix.
Now we can use the
function image,
which takes as an input the
"flower cl clusters" matrix.
And let's turn off the axes
by writing axes="false."
And now, going back to
our graphics window,
we can see our
segmented image here.
The darkest shade corresponds
to the background,
and this is actually associated
with the first cluster.
The one in the middle is
the core of the flower,
and this is cluster 2.
And then the petals
correspond to cluster 3,
which has the fairest
shade in our image.
Let us now check how the
original image looked.
Let's go back to the console
and then maximize it here.
So let's go back to
our image function,
but now this time the
input is the flower matrix.
And then let's keep
the axis as false.
But now, how about we add an
additional argument regarding
the color scheme?
Let's make it grayscale.
So we're going to
take the color,
and it's going to take
the function gray.
And the input to this
function is a sequence
of values that goes
from 0 to 1, which
actually is from black to white.
And then we have to
also specify its length,
and that's specified as 256,
because this corresponds
to the convention for grayscale.
And now, going
back to our image,
now we can see our original
grayscale image here.
You can see that it has a
very, very low resolution.
But in our next video,
we will try to segment
an MRI image of
the brain that has
a much, much higher resolution.